When we look at the clients
that we're dealing with
The key problems that they're facing
Are around how do they maintain
their IT infrastructure
While also adding value to the business
To allow those organizations to
focus their IT people on key skills
And key activities that
the business will value
They need to be able to
move their current workloads
Into that cloud context
without a massive investment
When we looked at that seamless
transition without conversion
We wanted to have a
VMware-based cloud solution
And clearly IBM Cloud with its
bare-metal server offering
Where we can run a complete VMware stack
Allows us to protect our client workloads
Onto a VMware platform with zero
conversion of their source virtual machine
And allow them to run it live in the cloud
And also revert back to an on-premise
After any incident that has happened
The entire experience is
completely seamless to the client
And ensures that they have minimal downtime
And minimum potential
disruption to their organization
In a disaster recovery solution
Typically clients would
have done big band tests
Once or twice a year where
they look at bringing
Large swathes of their technology live
To test that it's valid
And then they'd shut it down again
Very time intensive, it was very invasive
To the day-to-day operations
of most organizations
What our clients are now doing
Is on an ongoing basis
Moving workloads to the cloud
And allow them to run for
a period of days or weeks
In a live context
And then reverting them back
to their original location
Treating the cloud presence
As an extension of their
on premise environment
And that's giving them a
huge amount of flexibility
About how they approach
disaster recovery planning
And certainly on the
functionality of their systems
IBM as an organization have
being incredibly supportive
The consistency of the behavior,
the speed of delivery
The scale that we can
achieve with IBM Cloud
These are things we couldn't do previously
And these are elements
of a complex IT ecosystem
That we're exposing to our clients
In a way that wasn't possible previously